l'ambiance avait été lourde toute la
journée
anne vignot pouvait bien siroter un
dernier verre en tant que candidate je
me détends ici on est sur une belle
terrasse il fait bon
un peu d'air on a besoin de respirer ou
se détendre parce qu'on veut recevoir
les résultats en toute sérénité devant
elle un brouillon de discours en quatre
victoires mais elle hésite
le faible taux de participation
l'inquiète déjà ça m'a fait énormément
quel que soit le résultat de toute façon
je me trouvais du coup comme étant une
alerte les premiers résultats tombent
tous favorables à la candidate
écologiste
cela ne suffit pas pour détendre anne
vignot le temps est en train de tourner
tc
43 1 41 8 donc c'est bon sens foulani
torreilles courte mais la timide le
premier v de la victoire
les militants eux n'attendent pas la
confirmation des résultats très distant
x est en train de se passer
pezens on élit ce soir sa première femme
maire élie son premier sa première femme
maire écologiste
puis vient le tour de ses colistiers
socialistes communistes et citoyens qui
peuvent enfin l'a félicitée anne vignot
l'emportent à 43,9 %
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai que c'est vite dit 'confiant'
qui c'est avec eux que moi il ne change
dans cette cité cent cinq jours après le
premier tour anne vignot peut se lâcher
il faudra dire désormais madame la maire
vendredi prochain elle tiendra son
premier conseil municipal
[Applaudissements]